the New Hampshire primaries are here
Michael Bloomberg meets rough road as
old audio of him emerges on
stop-and-frisk
and we discuss what the nuclear family
was mistake I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro show is
sponsored by expressvpn your data is
your business protected at expressvpn
comm slash Ben well today New Hampshire
primaries and the voting has already
started in Dixville notch which is of
course this tiny little place in New
Hampshire where they vote really early
the first few voters voted surprisingly
for Michael Bloomberg Bloomberg's
getting some write-in votes which
demonstrates that there is real disquiet
I mean demonstrate that much cuz like
three voters but what it does
demonstrate is that there is some pretty
significant disquiet inside the
Democratic Party about exactly who ought
to be its nominee a lot of people very
very nervous about Bernie Sanders as
well they should be because the new
national polling has Bernie Sanders on
top not because he has really gained a
lot of ground but because Joe Biden is
absolutely collapsing in on himself like
a dying star it's unbelievable I mean
the man is turning into a polling black
hole there are two separate national
polls out and Joe Biden has collapsed in
both of them there's a Quinnipiac poll
that came out yesterday
it showed Bernie Sanders up at 25
percent which is not honestly like a
huge jump for him normally he's
somewhere between 20 and 23 so it's like
a slight increase for him but Joe Biden
who normally runs in the low 30s or high
20s is all the way down at 17% in that
Quinnipiac poll with Michael Bloomberg
polling at 15%
he hasn't even run a primary yet
Elizabeth Warren at 14 Pete Budaj
at 10 Amy Klobuchar at four okay and
when you break that down by white and
black voters Sanders is actually leading
him on white voters 20 to 16 over
Elizabeth Warren among black voters
Biden is still in the lead with 27%
that's not gonna be enough to carry him
over the top that gap between him and
the rest of the field has been shrinking
steadily in second place with black
voters in that Quinnipiac poll is
Michael Bloomberg knows we'll get to
that may not last depending on the
impact of some new audio that's come out
about Michael Bloomberg talking about
his stop-and-frisk policies in New York
and largely defending the fact that the
impact of the stop-and-frisk policies
just really kind of disproportionately
depends on how you measure the
proportionality felt largely let's say
on minority people in New York City
we'll get to audio of boom berg talking
about that which is creating a stir
today Bernie Sanders is running in third
place only eight percentage points
back among black voters in that
Quinnipiac poll so those are good
numbers for Bernie Sanders and horrible
horrible numbers for Joe Biden and
that's not the only poll that's horrible
for Biden today disastrous poll for
Monmouth hit previous poll from Monmouth
was January 16th through 20th Bernie
Sanders has gained only about three
points about 26% Joe Biden has collapsed
14 points in that poll nationally he's
now collapsed in most of the polls down
to second place which is a disaster for
him because again his entire pitch was
electability hey Joe Biden's entire
spiel here was I'm the person who is
most electable you have to put me up in
a general election because I'm gonna win
the problem is people when they hear
electable believe that electable is a
quality that translates from the
primaries to the general so they get the
logic wrong well Biden was always
arguing is that he was the most
electable in a general election matchup
against Trump and there's an argument
for that even though he doesn't do well
in primaries the problem is that
electability is not separated in the
public mind between primaries and
general election electability people
don't make that distinction so if you
say I'm super electable guys I'm most
electable and then you start losing
elections it's very difficult to recover
from that and look like captain
electability when it comes to a general
election so the overall perception of
electability in a general is indeed
affected even though it shouldn't be by
lack of electability in early states
like Iowa and New Hampshire where Biden
is completely falling down on the job in
that Monmouth poll by the way a couple
of the candidates who have been rising
Bloomberg's up to 11% in that Budaj Edge
is up to 13% in that poll Elizabeth
Warren has been dropping steadily as
well it would not be a grand surprise to
see Elizabeth Warren drop into third or
even fourth place Amy Klobuchar has been
getting some early support as well she
should because she is the most electable
Democrat who is not Joe Biden in a
general election in all of this and by
the way that that is pretty much what
this Quinnipiac poll shows the
Quinnipiac poll shows that there is that
everybody basically beats Trump on a
national level but again the Quinnipiac
poll is taken nationally it's not taken
in these various states the favorability
rating is where all of these Democrats
are in serious trouble okay because
right now the presumption is that a lot
of these Democrats are going to
outperform expectations because Trump is
so unpopular but the favorability
ratings for a lot of these Democrats are
really bad so let's go back to the
Quinnipiac poll for a second so it says
the Michael Bloomberg would beat from 51
to 42 that Sanders would beat
from 51 to 43 that Biden would beat from
50 to 43 which again kills Biden's
electability I recommend cuz if Sanders
is pulling better against Trump than
Biden is then what exactly is Biden's
argument Klobuchar would defeat from 49
43 Warren 4844 Buddha judge 47:43 now in
reality Trump who's an incumbent
president he's not gonna finish in 42 to
43 percent right he was polling at 42 to
43 percent in the last election cycle
and he ended up winning 46 percent of
the vote he's now the incumbent
president with a strong economy chances
our hands have closer to 48 or 49
percent of the vote but here is the real
problem for Democrats in that Quinnipiac
poll Elizabeth Warren has a negative
favorability rating a 39 percent
favorability rating that is lower than
Trump's Biden has a 43 percent
favorability rating which is about the
same as Trump's Bloomberg has a 34
percent favorability rating 25 percent
have not heard enough about him to get
him higher than that so he's underwater
by about six points Biden's underwater
by seven Warren it's underwater by eight
Sanders has a 44 percent negative
favorability rating Budaj Edge has a
positive favorability rating but only
36% of people say they're positive about
him because 31% haven't heard enough
about him and Klobuchar has 32 percent
positive 44 percent have not heard
enough about her president Trump even
ins Quinnipiac poll it shows that
President Trump is at the highest point
of his presidency in the pew poll in
terms of favorability he's at 43%
favorable which again is very
competitive with all these other
Democrats the only Democrat who's ahead
of him and this is within the margin of
error is Sanders at 44% everybody else
is well behind president Trump and he
scores high marks on his handling of the
economy
54% of voters even in this Quinnipiac
poll approve of his handling of the
economy independents approved 59 percent
to 37 percent so Trump is in very strong
shape heading into this election cycle
the Democrats are collapsing and Joe
Biden in particular is completely
collapsing and so everybody is looking
for an alternative the alternative for
the moment was supposed to be Pete
Bhutto judge we'll get to that in just
one second we're gonna get the Sanders
and Buddha judge and really Bloomberg
who was seen as sort of the guy waiting
in the wings and obviously the person
that Trump is worried about we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about making our business more efficient
so something that you don't think about
when you have a small business too much
and it's one of the things that really
can come back and bite you directly in
the butt is HR issues you really don't
think about it too much because what you
have
fifteen employees are you really gonna
have HR issues well the minute that
somebody goes to the Department of Labor
over something that you haven't thought
about then it becomes a major time and
money suck this is why you need Bambi
right we spend a lot of money on HR but
you don't have to spend a lot of money
on HR because you have a small business
why should you spend a ton of money on
HR if you hired an HR specialist just to
come and work at your company it's in
cost you fifty sixty seventy thousand
dollars a year instead why don't you go
check out Bambi right now Bambi spell ba
MBE was created specifically for small
business you get a dedicated HR manager
they craft HR policy they maintain your
compliance all for just 99 bucks a month
this isn't just some sort of hotline
that you're calling up some person picks
up in India it's like a dedicated HR
specialist who's gonna help you write
all your policies help you deal with the
government in case something crops up
make sure make sure that you are in
compliance with all applicable law
because laws can widely vary between
jurisdictions as far as for example
minimum wage or hours work their
overtime all that kind of stuff
Bambi makes sure that you are on the
ball with all of this stuff your
dedicated HR manager is available by
phone email or real-time chat from
onboarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business and
help you manage your employees day to
day all for just 99 bucks a month
month-to-month no hidden fees you can
cancel anytime this really is a solid
solid deal go to Bambi comm slash repair
that's BA MBE e.com slash apparel right
now and schedule your free HR audit
that's Bambi comm slash Shapiro spelled
BAM B EE comm slash apparel Bambi
dot-com
slash Shapiro and save yourself lots of
time you're not lower your downside risk
when it comes to HR issues and even do
all of it for 99 bucks a month as
opposed to spending thousands and
thousands of dollars every year on this
sort of thing spell its BAM B e.com
slash Shapiro go check I get that free
HR audit okay so with Joe Biden
collapsing into the mud I mean
absolutely collapsing this means that
his last cap gasp is Nevada he's not
gonna make it to South Carolina he'll
stick around until South Carolina just
for the craps and giggles of it right
mean he has to because his entire pitch
is that he's gonna win a
disproportionate share of black voters
well he's collapsing in the black vote
right Michael Bloomberg is chipping away
at that which is unbelievable because
again Michael Bloomberg is widely
perceived by the radical left on Twitter
to be a racist
I mean Bloomberg is racist is trending
today the reason that Bloomberg is
racist is trending today is because
there's audio that came out of Michael
Bloomberg in 2000
fifteen at the Aspen Institute talking
specifically about stop and frisk policy
now one of the things that I think is
necessary to understand what Bloomberg
is saying here is so he's being accused
of racism because he's saying that stop
and frisk disproportionately affected
black communities black and Hispanic
communities in New York City in order to
determine whether that's true whether
it's disproportionately affecting black
and Hispanic communities the question is
what proportionality are you using right
we're just gonna analyze the content of
what he is saying and then we'll get to
the effect of what he's saying because
the effect of what he's saying is
obviously very bad here articulates this
in the worst possible way but in order
to understand I've talked about this on
the program before whether stop and
frisk policy was disproportionately
affecting minorities the question is
what are you comparing it to are you
comparing the number of people stopped
and frisked in a particular community to
the general population demographic of a
community or are you comparing it to
crime rates and that makes a huge
difference right because if you were to
say if I was just gonna tell you 50% of
the people in prison in the United
States for murder are black which is
about corrected somewhere between 45 and
50 percent last I checked you would
immediately say well it's just
proportionate that's a disproportionate
number because 13% of black Americans
are black people so a 50% of the people
in jail for murder are black that must
mean that something disproportionate is
happening that's criminal justice racism
except that murder is a specific crime
that is reported basically 100% of the
time and so the question is not the
population of murderers who are black
compared to the population of blacks who
are American right the question is the
population of murderers were black
compares the number of murder suspects
who are black right in other words was
there a white suspects and they just
went in the rest of the black guy in
thrown in jail so the same thing is true
of stop and frisk if you actually want
to talk about the proportionality of how
many people were stopped and frisked by
race then you have to compare that so
the reported crime rates you can't
compare that to the demographics to take
a quick example heavy percentage of the
population of New York City is Jewish
the crime rate in the Jewish community
in New York City is extraordinarily low
are we really going to suggest that the
proportionality of people stopped and
frisked has to be done not on the basis
of crime reports or crime areas but has
to be done on the basis of sure
population that would make no sense
whatsoever I mean that's not what the
police are there to do so if you
actually want to establish
disproportionality what you would have
to do is demonstrate that the police are
over
profiling right they are over stopping
and frisking black and Hispanic people
in comparison to the crime rate in New
York City among black and Hispanic
people and so that that is why all of
the talk about stop and frisk
disproportionately affecting black and
Hispanic people it depends on what you
are using as your numerator it depends
what you are using is your numr are you
using the demographic profile generally
of New York or the criminal profile of
New York which is a different profile
from the same thing would hold true if I
were to say to you 99% of people in jail
for violent crimes are men is that
disproportionate well its disproportion
in the sense that only 50% of the
population of the United States like
everyplace else is male but it's not
disproportion in the sense that
virtually all violent crime in the
United States is committed by men so
again the same thing holds with stop and
frisk I'm just gonna give you a few
statistics here so you understand why
stop and frisk policy is not inherently
racist despite the fact that a heavy
percentage of the people who are stopped
and frisked and really a stop question
and frisk is the actual Supreme Court
approved policy it's not the police
we're supposed to be able to just walk
up to people and then Pat them down it's
supposed to be that you have a
reasonable suspicion that the person is
carrying a gun or carrying a banned
knife by the way if you've ever worked
with police officers I mean I won't quit
security all the time right I've been in
rooms where the police who are working
with me where the officers who are
working with me can spot a gun on
somebody's hip or they can spot a knife
on somebody's hip and they can do so
with extraordinary accuracy I mean when
you see people walking around a certain
way for a long enough time then you
actually get pretty good at telling when
they are carrying a foreign object on
their body in any case here are some of
the statistics in New York City that
Bloomberg is gonna be talking about here
okay so this is according to Heather
McDonald she says who is killing and
shooting black crime victims
overwhelmingly not whites not the police
but tragically other blacks the high
black homicide victimization rate is a
function of the black homicide
commission rate blacks commit homicide
nationally at 7 times 7 times the rate
of whites and most Hispanics combined
black males between the age of 14 and 17
commit homicide of 10 times the rate of
white and most Hispanic males between
the ages of 14 and 17 officer-involved
shootings are not responsible for the
black homicide victimization rate either
in fact a greater percentage of white
and Hispanic homicide victims are killed
by a police officer than black homicide
victims in 2015
12% of all whites and Hispanics who died
of homicide were killed by cop compared
with 4 percent of black homicide victims
who were killed by cop nor is white
violence responsible for the black
victimization right blacks commit vote
most in
racial crime between 2012 and 2015 there
were 630 1830 violent interracial
victimizations excluding homicide
between blacks and whites blacks
committed 85.5% of those violent
victimizations are 540,000 360 felonious
assaults on whites while whites
committed fourteen point four percent of
those violent victimizations or 90 1470
felonious assaults on blacks these now
here's the important part these national
disparities are repeated locally in New
York City for example blacks 23% of the
population committed 71 percent of all
gun violence in 2016
whites who had 34% of the population are
the city's largest racial group
committed less than 2% of all shootings
okay so to go back to the
proportionality argument that that I am
making here if you were to compare the
population of New York City you would
say okay well 34 percent of the
population is white thirty percent
thirty four percent of the people who
are pulled over and stopped and frisked
should be white except that's stupid
because whites constitute two percent of
all the shootings so why would use frisk
34 percent of the people thirty four
percent of the time when it's really two
percent of the crime why would you frisk
them 34 percent of the time doesn't make
any sense
these identifications as Heather
McDonald are provided by the victims of
and witnesses to those shootings
overwhelmingly minorities themselves a
black New Yorker is less fifty times
more likely to commit a shooting at than
a white New Yorker in Chicago blacks and
whites are each a little under a third
of the city's population blacks commit
80% of all shootings White's a little
over one percent making blacks in the
Windy City 80 times more likely to
commit a shooting than whites in Oakland
blacks committed 83 percent of homicides
attempted homicides robberies assaults
with firearms and assaults with weapons
other than firearms in 2013 even though
they constitute only 28% of Oakland's
population whites were 1% of robbery
suspects 1% of firearm assault suspects
and an even lower percent of homicide
suspects even though they make up about
34 percent of the city's population in
Pittsburgh 82 percent of known homicide
suspects were black in 2015 even though
the Pittsburgh population is just 26
percent black in st. Louis nearly 100%
of homicide suspects were black through
December 22nd 2017 though the population
is 47 percent white and 47 percent black
and as Heather McDonald points out the
vast majority of black residents in
high-crime areas in elsewhere are
law-abiding and hardworking and they
deserve the same freedom from fear as
residents of safer neighborhoods and
they begged for more proactive police
enforcement as reporters from the
Baltimore Sun in Washington Post both
discovered when covering the
for math of the Freddie gray riots okay
so she's not making a case the racist
case here would be the blacks are
inherently more inclined to commit crime
no one is making that case because it's
absurd and ridiculous on its face the
question is whether it is racist if you
apply a stop and frisk policy that hits
on a population level disproportionately
particular groups but on a crime level
it's exactly proportionally those
particular groups whether that is racist
okay that is the backdrop to Michael
Bloomberg's commentary so we're gonna
get to what Michael Bloomberg actually
said that has some trending as hashtag
Bloomberg is racist in just one second
despite the fact that under Bloomberg's
tutelage of the city like really the one
bright spot of his mayoral T was the
continuing drop in crime rates in New
York City that started under Rudy
Giuliani and then continued on through
Michael Bloomberg largely because of
policies like broken windows policing
and stop-and-frisk policies that were
taking place in New York City proactive
policing put putting cops on street
corners that were known to be high crime
the the use of measures like ComStat in
order to determine high crime areas and
then target those exact precincts right
all of that is really Bloomberg's major
achievement he's had to run against that
because he's afraid of being labeled
racist by the media it's not gonna save
him one iota because as it turns out he
has said stuff defending his own record
before we're gonna get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
difficulty of going to an auto parts
store when something breaks in your car
so how often this happened to me
something breaks in my car I don't know
much about cars I go to the auto parts
store some guy some schlub behind the
counter he tells me about some generic
part that that I can buy and then it's
easy to install don't worry you'll go
home it'll be easy to do I go in i buy
the part I go home I have no clue how to
install it because I'm not an auto
expert and not only that the part
doesn't fit anyway I bring it to my
mechanic and he's like well this is the
wrong part why did you even buy this
thing well I'm not an auto expert but if
you are an auto expert it's even worse
because why would you walk into an auto
parts store and then buy some generic
part for an overpriced price instead of
getting an exact part that you need this
is why you need Rock Auto calm the
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts the rockauto.com catalog it's
unique it's remarkably easy to navigate
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brands specifications and prices you
prefer rockauto.com has everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or daily
driver get everything you need in a few
is
clicks delivered directly to your door
rockauto.com it's a family business it
serves autoparts customers they've been
doing it online for 20 years which cuts
out the middleman go to Rock Auto come
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck you're not gonna
be able to do it any better anywhere
else right shapiro in there how did you
hear about us box and they know that we
sent you that's Rock Auto calm right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right now right your peer on
that hair did you hear about his box
okay so back to stop inference policies
and proactive policing so the fact is in
the United States crime rates between
1960 and 1994 spiked dramatically in
major cities across the country in the
early 1990s a lot of cities began to use
proactive policing
in order to lower crime rates and the
United States underwent one of the
greatest crime transformations in
history we lowered our murder rate
dramatically in major cities across the
country okay and that was because of
proactive policing and broken windows
policing and ComStat and yes policies
like stop question and frisk and these
were platted in bipartisan fashion and
Mayor Giuliani became mayor Giuliani
because David Dinkins wasn't gonna do
any of this stuff Mayor Richard Riordan
in LA became mayor Richard Riordan
because Democrats in LA we're not doing
this sort of stuff and the attempt to
clean up crime was one of the major
American success stories between 1994
and 2015 when there was sort of a
reverse effect after some of the
Ferguson riots and the so-called
Ferguson effect where police started
backing off out of fear that they were
going to ruin their lives and careers if
they engaged in proactive policing well
this was a bipartisan coalition that
favored lowering crime and that
bipartisan coalition included a lot of
black legislators and a lot of black
City Council members who were sick of
watching high crime neighborhoods
affecting black people who are living in
those high crime neighborhoods okay so
that's the backdrop to all of this so
Michael Bloomberg's great success story
in New York City really is that he was
able to continue lowering crime and
that's the only reason he can run for
president Svea not lowered crime he'd be
like Mayor Bill DeBlasio had a complete
failure of a campaign right Mayor
Bloomberg's basic pitch is I made the
city of New York safer I turn x I helped
continue the transformation of Times
Square from what was a squalid cesspool
into a pretty nice place to be can take
your kids you can walk around it kinda
like Disneyland right and that that is
Bloomberg's pitch but he's had to run
directly away from that pitch because
he's running directly into the teeth of
a bunch of the the woke warriors who
suggest that proactive policing is
inherently racist okay so he's at the
Aspen Institute now the piece of audio
you're about
here we don't hear the beginning of the
audio the reason I think this is kind of
important honestly is cuz you don't know
it was a Q&A session you don't know what
question he was asked so the way that
the audio sounds it's like he's
volunteering that they were targeting
black people and maybe that's what he
said and if he did say that and he is
expressing this all wrong right in very
bad fashion but if he was asked which I
have a feeling he was why stop and frisk
disproportionally affected black and
hispanic people and he gave this answer
and the answer might be rough but the
answer is also based in in fact which is
that the crime rates in the black and
hispanic community in our city are
dramatically higher than the crime rates
in other areas of New York City and this
is why the police are in those areas and
this is why the arrest rates are
disproportionate to population
statistics okay so here's what Bloomberg
had to say at the Aspen Institute it's
got Bloomberg is racist trending and
we'll see if this has any impact on race
I'm kind of that full that it does
honestly like I'm kind of doubtful they
are gonna see Bloomberg support in the
black community completely collapse in
the same way that Trump's support in
Hispanic community did not completely
collapse despite the fact that he was
saying all of these kind of ridiculous
and egregious things about about about
immigration generally and about Mexicans
and all this stuff because most people
of Mexican descent who live in the
country who support Trump are not
off-put by the fact that Trump speaks in
harsh language about illegal immigration
most black people in America are not I
think that the the amount of black
support for letting people out of prison
who have committed crimes is way lower
than the mainstream media would have you
believe I think they're I think the vast
majority I mean I don't think I know the
vast majority of black Americans are
law-abiding people who want to live in
safe communities and so when they are
told that the police are supposed to be
out of their communities the police
aren't inherently bad and all this I
don't think most black Americans believe
that which is why Joe Biden who said a
lot of similar things to what you're
gonna hear Bloomberg say right here his
support has not cratered with black
Americans either here is Michael
Bloomberg talking this Capote this is
supposedly the clip that's gonna end his
presidential
[Music]
yes that's true why'd you do it
professor all the private and love the
way that we've gotten to other kitchen
okay now he's saying this in the
roughest and dumbest possible fashion is
to get the weight get the guns out of
hands you throw them up against the wall
and you're frisked um well or if you
asked any police officer in your city
you stop you questioning you frisk right
that is the actual legal language so the
minute long excerpts Bloomberg says 95%
of your murders murderers and murder
victims fit one MO you can just take the
description Xerox it and pass it out to
all of the cops right so this is why
whether he was asked about the racial
disproportion is sort of relevant to how
he's answering if he's defending the
policy on the basis that it is
disproportionate to the general
demographic then that's a problem if
he's defending the the just of the
supposed to disproportion on the basis
of crime statistics then he's saying it
in rough fashion what he's saying is
basically correct right what he's saying
is basically true on a factual level
which is that disproportionately the
vast majority of crime victims from
murder to violent crime to robbery in in
the city of New York are minorities and
the and the disproportionate number of
of perpetrators and suspects our members
of these communities too so who do you
think that that active policing is going
to end up hitting more often and this is
also true for marijuana statistics so
you have more cop if you have more cops
in high crime areas and those high crime
areas are disproportionately minority
and presumably disproportionately people
who are smoking pot in front of the cops
in those areas are going to be ones who
are arrested when people say why aren't
the cops hanging out around Wall Street
because they're in street crime around
without straight that's why because the
cops are where the street crime is there
where the violent crime is it's a
completely different division that
investigates white-collar crime you want
to up the white-collar crime element in
New York City you're not gonna call NYPD
when you see a white-collar crime right
you're gonna call a specific division
presumably of the DOJ right you're not
gonna call like the beat cop you're not
gonna flag down on a cop car you're not
gonna flag down on a patrol car and be
like I saw a man engaging an insider
trading in the elevator over on Wall
Street now that's not how that any of
that works okay and that's what
Bloomberg is saying he says that's true
in New York that's true in virtually
every city you want to spend the money
to put a lot of cops on the street put
those cops are the crime is which means
in minority neighborhoods
okay well that's awkwardly put but that
is true which is that the crime is
disproportionately in areas that have a
disproportionate number of minorities
that just is the fact he's a Bloomberg
is getting
created for this he then made a second
statement about this that's all we also
going around we'll get to all of this in
just one second and what this does to
Michael Bloomberg's campaign hopes first
let's talk about a fantastic Valentine's
Day gifts like a very important
Valentine's Day gift so you have a
special someone out there and that's
special someone needs jewelry okay you
know that this is true and the fact it
like my wife big into jewelry where am I
gonna get jewelry for my wife I'm gonna
go directly to the source I'm gonna go
to the pearl source why well number one
I trust the people who run it like I'm
good friends with the people who run the
pearl source absolutely trustworthy
their stuff is just gorgeous my wife has
a pearl necklace from the pearl source
she has earrings from the pearl source
you can customize your jewelry at the
pearl source it's the largest selection
of pearls available anywhere each
jewelry piece is custom made just for
you you can customize your jewelry based
on pearl size quality gold type length
and many more choices and you're getting
the highest quality pearl jewelry at up
to 70% off retail prices if you need it
quickly for Valentine's Day like you're
running out because it's right around
the corner the pearl source offers free
two-day shipping on every order so like
do it right now and you're not gonna
have to worry everything comes
beautifully packaged in elegant jewelry
box ready to be presented as soon as it
arrives if you're not sure she's gonna
love the gifts no worries there either
because the ProSource comes with a no
hassle 60-day money-back guarantee so it
is indeed risk-free for a limited time
listeners to my show can take an
additional 14 percent off your entire
order on Valentine's Day go to the Pearl
source calm /ban and her promo club
Bennett check out you get 14 percent off
your entire order for Valentine's Day
and I got a couple days to make this
thing right dude don't screw it up go to
the Pearl source comm slash been enter
promo code been at checkout get 14
percent off go straight to the source
the Pearl source again beautiful jewelry
from people you can trust because I know
them personally I'm friends with the
people who run the Pearl source really
like I would trust them to watch my kids
let alone sell me jewelry so go check
them out right now the Pearl source comm
slash men enter promo code been at
checkout right now okay so a second
comment from Michael Bloomberg has
materialized as well both of these are
trending on Twitter because the way this
works that Michael Bloomberg's again his
only pitch for being President of the
United States is that he was a
half-decent mayor of New York City that
involved lowering the crime rates but in
the Democratic Party you're not supposed
to run on lowering crime rates you're
supposed to run on woken us and that
means that you are supposed to run on
the basic presupposition that if a
disproportionate number to the
demographic population of blacks and
Hispanics are arrested that must reflect
criminal justice racism as opposed to
disproportionate crimes taking place
black and hispanic suspects here is
michael bloomberg saying another thing
that is getting him torn up is on wor
radio in new york they just keep saying
oh it's a disportionateately in that
case incidentally I think we dis
fortunately stopped White's too much and
minorities too little okay that is a
100% true he's gettin ripped up for this
right yeah how could he say this what he
just said on a factual basis is 100%
true on the basis of crime statistics if
you were just to compare crime reports
to numbers of stops and frisks
what you see is that black and hispanic
suspects are being pulled over less
frequently than they are charged in
terms of the in terms of the general
crime statistics o bloomer is getting
ripped up and down and presumably
bloomberg is gonna come out and
apologize now if you had any stones
bloomberg would say listen my policies
helped save literally thousands of black
and hispanic lives in new york city
proactive policing saves lives if you
want to lower crime rates and that
disproportionately affects people who
are living in minority communities which
are high crime areas if you want to
increase the economic growth in those
areas you need more policing not less
that is why i've been very much
questioning the criminal justice reform
proposals of the trump administration
I'm not sure that letting more criminals
out onto the streets is a solution to
the to the investments and growth
problems in minority areas of the
country right the going concern has been
that there are too many black men in
prison that if they go back they're
gonna go back to their kids they're
gonna go back to their their girlfriends
or spouses they're gonna form nuclear
families they're gonna be part of the
rebuilding of the social fabric in these
areas that may be true for some but a
lot of these people are gonna be
recidivists and then they're going to
increase the crime rates in these
particular communities the fact is one
of the great miraculous stories of the
last half-century in the United States
is the lower end crime rate between 1994
and 2015 to blow that on the basis of
political correctness seems weird to me
and damaging highly damaging to minority
Americans but again the media drive this
stuff by suggesting that stop and frisk
itself was inherently racist as opposed
to a reaction to the to the fact that
there were high crime rates in New York
State now I will say this about
Bloomberg and Bloomberg openly says here
that the problem of high crimes is
largely relegated to big cities and a
fortunately is identifiable in minority
communities particularly that it's a
proportionate number of gun suspects in
New York City like and he says like
every other major city is happening
among young minority males okay and then
his proposal is to disarm all Americans
so I'm gonna need him to explain that
one I'm gonna I'm really I need him to
square that circle for me because
remember he's one of the big gun control
pushers nationally his suggestion is
that everyone's had their gun taken away
from them well if you are in favor of
targeted crime in things like stop and
frisk then why are you also in favor of
broad crime policies that would remove
guns from presumably tens of millions of
law-abiding Americans who have nothing
to do with the elevated rates of crime
in places like New York City and by the
way if you look at state crime rates
they're disproportionately located in
major cities okay so we're gonna get to
more of this in just a second because is
it possible that this is the ends of
sort of the bloomberg hope and if so
who's that least standing if Bloomberg
starts to collapse and Biden is
collapsing well that leaves really to
write P Budi judge and Amy Klobuchar
because everybody is sort of starting to
wake up to the fact that Bernie Sanders
is going to be a disaster for their
party like really a disaster also Bernie
is you know he's kind of fibbing now
right like Bernie said he's gonna
release his medical records and now he's
saying well not so fast
I don't need to release my medical
records why would I release cold records
yeah I'm not yours yeah mine I guess
we'll have to nationalize his medical
records in order to see them we'll get
to that interest at one second first
let's talk about your life insurance
policy now let's say that you had taken
out a life insurance policy on Joe
Biden's campaign well you would be
cashing in right now because his
campaign is just this far from being
declared dead but who could have
foreseen that in the past the answer is
very few it's very difficult to predict
the future this is why you should have
life insurance and it's also I should
have home insurance it's why I should
have disability insurance and auto
insurance you should have all the types
of insurance you need because you can't
tell what's gonna happen in the future
policy genius con will compare your
policy against options from top insurers
and make sure for example on home
insurance that you are getting the right
home insurance coverage at the best
possible price they've saved their
customers an average of 690 bucks per
year doing just that if policy genius
finds you a better rate than what you're
currently paying they'll do all the work
to get you switched if you own a car
policy genius will compare your home and
auto policies across different insurers
they'll even mix and match to find new
savings get home insurance at policy
genius calm in minutes you can get the
ball rolling on a policy for a new home
or you can reshape your current policy
policy genius because let's be real
about this
you can never predict the future all you
can do is make sure that you are insured
against the possibility of disaster and
this is why policy genius is so helpful
if you're a responsible human being you
need insurance on all these things your
life home Auto to sit like all of these
things so go check them out right now a
policy genius com get it done quickly
get it done easily the Internet makes
competitive shopping super easy and
policy genius helps you out on the
insurance level policy genius comm
that's policy genius.com can we get back
into this 2020 race in just one second
last week I told you about this awesome
podcast the cold war what we saw over
the weekend this podcast reach number
one in history podcast number five on
all Apple podcasts so now you know it's
not just me saying it it really is
terrific I mean I've been listening to
it myself it's fantastic the story is
well told the setting is brilliantly
descriptive you get a sense of what it
was like to live through major events
like the Berlin Airlift the Korean War
the Cuban Missile Crisis the space race
these milestones are tied together to
give you a sense of the big picture the
apocalypse that never happened they've
already released two episodes of this 12
part series so you have some to catch up
on you should go listen now because it
has never been more relevant than this
year where the left has gone full-blown
communists I mean Bernie Sanders would
have been on and was in many ways on the
wrong side of the Cold War and now the
Democrats want to nominate that guy this
podcast emphasizes the battle not only
for capitalism but for civilization
itself a battle that we have to refight
in every generation just go to daily
wire.com slash Cold War start listening
it's this incredibly important story it
is really superbly told that is daily
wire calm slash cold war also folks if
you haven't noticed already this this
year's just wild I mean we're like not
even halfway through February and it is
just crazy towns well if you want all
the updates you really should go over to
daily wire comm become a member and you
get comprehensive news and opinion from
us on demand we are giving you right now
20% off all memberships this promotion
is ending tomorrow so don't wait any
longer get 20% off all memberships when
you use promo code DW 2020 members get
our articles had free access to all of
our live broadcast and show library the
full three hours of the Ben Shapiro show
select bonus content access to the
mailbag and now my election insight
op-eds plus our new OU access tier gets
you into live online Q&A discussions
with me and Andrew Klavan Matt Walsh
Michael moles plus our sites writers and
special guests let us to answer your
questions help you stay one step ahead
of the rabid left if you haven't already
download the daily wired app also our
app is fantastic like it's really
well-designed again all of this is
ending tomorrow so don't wait
it's out that's promo code DW 2024 20%
off like that ends tomorrow get it done
right now joined today stay informed on
all things 2020 you are listening to the
largest fastest corn conserved a podcast
and radio show in the nation
[Music]
already so Michael Bloomberg supposedly
gonna take a serious hit for this audio
we will see whether that is just in the
Twitter universe or whether that's in
the real world because there is this
massive divided between the Twitterati
and the real world the Twitterati will
provide you with your base they'll
provide you with your core right that's
what Bernie Sanders found out super
active on Twitter but are they brilliant
enough to drive you over the top now I
don't want to say that Twitter doesn't
matter because Joe Biden basically said
Twitter didn't matter and now Joe Biden
like both physically and also his
campaign are sort of a smoldering wreck
but but the fact is that Twitter is not
real life and so if Michael Bloomberg is
going to collapse on the basis of this
what we'll see we'll see whether these
comments actually make a difference
I'm pretty sure that everybody knew that
Michael Bloomberg was the stop-and-frisk
guy the bigger problem for Michael
Bloomberg is in authenticity
if you campaigned on stop-and-frisk for
years and defendants stop-and-frisk for
years and then five minutes ago you
decided to run as a Democrat for the
presidential nomination and then
repudiated your own legacy that's a
problem see here's the thing about
Bernie he has never repudiated any form
of his own legacy instead he just says I
start didn't cook so a long time ago but
he's never repudiated anything he's ever
said in the 60s and 70s Joe Biden has
spent half this campaign repudiating his
own support for a 1994 crime bill which
contributed to again that lowered crime
rate none of these Democrats actually
have the stones to just stand on their
own record and say yeah I did that and
it may be unpopular now but it was the
right thing to do because lower crime
rates and saved a lot of lives
specifically in minority communities but
Bernie Sanders had never had to
repudiate anything because when you are
radical and pure you never have to
repudiate anything you've ever said that
this is it's funny you'll see folks on
the Left very often there'll be somebody
on the right who says something and it
is racially tinged a racist and people
on the Left will say why didn't you ask
this person earlier I'll be like well
yeah we did like well like we did it now
when Steve King came out and made
ridiculous comments and the entire
Republican Party went yeah that's bad we
should probably condemn that and like
not give him chairmanships and all that
kind of stuff and then the Democrats
were like well why didn't you do that
before with Steve King let me ask you a
question
when was the last time a Democrat was
ejected from the Democratic Party for
anything ideological not for doing
something corrupt right not for doing
something like sexual picadillo or
something doing something ideologically
wrong when was the last time a Democrat
was was ejected for being too far to the
left too radical it has never happened
like the last time I can remember it
happening with Cynthia McKinney when she
was open saying openly anti-semitic
back in like 2003 and if Cynthia
McKinney were around today
she'd be part of the squad because what
she was saying in 2003 is identical to
the stuff that Ilhan Omar Rashida Talib
say today and are honored for inside the
Democratic Party so again it is it is
pretty incredible
that all of the Democrats have
accomplished things like Michael
Bloomberg are gonna have to repudiate
their own policies unless you're a
useless communist like Bernie Sanders in
which case you repudiate nothing and
then you get to run as the authentic
candidate and they're saying the quiet
part out loud right Cynthia Nixon who's
a very wealthy actress from Sex in the
City and then she ran for governor
against Andrew Cuomo and got absolutely
smoked right Cynthia Nixon was rallying
for Sanders they had a big rally last
night and she said we don't just want
the crumbs anymore the crumbs we want
the whole pie which is just pure class
warfare garbage language can we explain
something what you get in the United
States is not crumbs what you got in the
United States is a share of the greatest
experiment in human history and also the
greatest prosperity in human history
like where are these crumbs of which you
speak Cynthia Nixon who's worth millions
of dollars where are these crumbs I'm
confused where Bernie Sanders has a lake
house like what are you talking about
and here's Cynthia Nixon basically
suggesting that we nationalize all
wealth and redistribute it because we
want the whole pie we who is we and what
is the whole pie and why is it do you
think that the pie is fixed because you
don't understand basic econ here's
Cynthia Nixon rallying for Sanders
because of Bernie Sanders and because of
what do you spent his life doing and how
he has changed this country in the last
four years he has taught me and he has
taught us as a country what we can ask
for we have we have made do with crumbs
for so long and Bernie has said hey
we're starving in this country we can't
subsist on these crumbs anymore
why can't we demand the whole pie why
can't we demand the whole pie mean this
is just pure Russian Revolution lines
right why can't we demand what demand
from whom from whom like if you don't
create you know is it so funny the folks
on the Left will say things like Jeff
Bezos you didn't build that because
there are roads man cuz there are roads
and it's like well okay if we are going
to just price in
to Jeff Bezos as well the value of roads
that are publicly owned would that
represent like 1% of the value of Amazon
the fact that there are roads right or
would that represent like not all that
much value at all compared to the vast
majority of the brand building that
Amazon has done or is it really the
infrastructure that's responsible for
that these if that's the case then why
doesn't Amazon exist in Estonia or
Latvia they have roads there too it
turns out roads are pretty common and
have been common since the Roman era so
like what are you talking about but the
same people who will say that Jeff Bezos
didn't build that will proclaim that we
want the whole pipe well you didn't
build that Cynthia Nixon you didn't
build any of that what right do you have
to demand something that you didn't
build this is why when people say that
socialism is about altruism it's not
it's about greed it's about you didn't
build that and now you want a piece of
something that you didn't build because
you are breathing and you are here well
guess what that is not altruistic that
is just you being selfish socialism is
inherently selfish because it demands
that's the whole point you're never here
to socialist talk about us giving it's
always what we demand it's always what
we want it's like my three-year-old when
he desperately wants another popsicle
it's all about what you want it's never
about what you're willing to give it's
so funny all the people who are who are
capitalist tend to talk about the
sacrifices that you make in order to
engage in transactions they tend to talk
about the amount of work they do what
does the last time you heard about a
socialist talk about the amount of work
they do as opposed to what they demand
for the work well you can make it a man
but that demand should not be backed by
a government gun in any case Bernie
Sanders he is now reversing himself on
his medical records on Sunday Sanders
reversed his position on medical records
saying he would not release
comprehensive medical records about his
health reneging on a promise he made in
September that he would absolutely
release his medical records before the
Democratic primary season began is
according to Hank Burien over at Daily
wire speaking on Sundays Meet the Press
host Chuck Todd pointed out to Sanders
what he had said in September before he
had a heart attack in early October
Sanders doubled down in late October he
said I want to make it comprehensive I
will probably begin lumpia aap continued
campaign manager if I use Shakir later
said more definitively Sanders does plan
to release the records by the end of
December but then he didn't write Chuck
Todd said the first votes have already
been cast you didn't release your
medical records he released a few
letters nobody interviewed your doctors
you did have a heart attack apparently
shouldn't the voters see your medical
records
before Super Tuesday sander said we've
released as much documentation I think
as any other kind of it and Chuck Todd
said right but nobody else had a heart
attack in the last expense and Sandra
said well look like him know know what
the candidates doing four or five events
running around the country and Todd said
right like you've proven your mettle but
you have your verduras that are
concerned about your age and Sanders
said I mean you couldn't start releasing
medical records and it never ends
we have released a substantive pot all
of our backgrounds we have doctors
cardiologists confirming I am in good
health Yahoo News notes that Sanders
released three brief letters from
doctors in December that declared he was
in good health currently but he's not
released his full medical records which
again he's not going to release those
full medical records because that's the
thing about heart attacks guys you look
like you're really vital until the
moment you have a heart attack and then
you don't look quite so vital right
Sanders look vital before the heart
attack and he had a heart attack I think
it would be good to know whether that
heart attack is going to reoccur being
in good medical health at this point
does not suggest that you're gonna be in
good medical health two minutes from now
if you don't release those medical
records but Bernie's not gonna release
that because he thinks he's gonna win
based on hiding that stuff also the
Democratic Party is getting more and
more nervous about mobilizing behind
Bernie Sanders Dave Wagle who's a Bernie
kind of acolyte and fan right he has a
piece today titled Sanders may be on the
verge of another New Hampshire win
Democrats aren't ready to get behind him
this is according to the Washington Post
he says that in the contest final hour
Sanders has minimized his own criticism
of the party pitching his campaign has a
chance for the state to get things right
and pick an electable candidate who will
supercharge a voter enthusiasm but
Sanders had already won New Hampshire
once by a 21-point landslide unlikely to
beat him here rival candidates and
skeptical voters are still asking
whether Sanders and his movement could
be trusted to win a general election and
you can see that people are very nervous
about this gavin newsom the garbage
Governor of California
he says you nervous about pretty much
all the Democrats he says that we're all
anxious about Sanders and Bloomberg and
Warren and all these people as well they
should be talking to all the governor's
last 48 hours there's deep anxiety that
we're not publicly communicating around
what is potentially emerging as a Bernie
Sanders ascendancy with the Elizabeth
Warren wing of the party and the
prospects as you were mentioning the
last segment that
berg moves into that and you are in a
place of civil war it's not my point of
view per se but it is the anxiety that
is I think spoken very much universally
spoken okay well you know that again is
the well-received wisdom inside the
Democratic Party everybody is very
nervous about Sanders as well they
should be meanwhile president Trump has
had a triumphal couple of weeks he held
a big rally again last night people wait
out in the rain and the snow for hours
on end to get into Trump's rallies very
entertaining dude he said yesterday we
are indeed more enthusiastic than the
Democrats by the way this is what the
polls are showing is that Republicans
are in fact more enthusiastic than
Democrats and Bernie's turnout numbers
are not good right everybody is burying
the lead in Iowa the lead is not that
Bernie Sanders performed low in Iowa or
the Peabody Jets performed well in Iowa
it's that nobody showed up that was
Hillary Clinton's big problem in 2016
and the Democrats are betting pure and
simple on the idea that Trump is
unpopular to launch them to victory
right as Chris Hayes right Chris Hayes
on MSNBC he was saying guys we shouldn't
beat we shouldn't be anxious people
don't like Donald Trump here's Chris
Hayes trying to trying to gin up the
base it ain't gonna work the idea that
this is some terrifyingly popular
juggernaut is just not borne out by the
facts almost all of what the president
is doing and has done independent of the
state of the economy which is a big if
right the stuff he's actually doing
almost all that is wildly unpopular he
is weak he's vulnerable politically he's
beatable he wants you to believe that
he's strong he's not he is not a
colossus he's a con man okay well good
luck with this because this is exactly
what Hillary Clinton said and then
nobody showed up because it turns out
nobody's enthused about what you guys
are pitching and here's Trump yesterday
at a rally in Manchester New Hampshire
drawing bigger crowds than any of the
Democrats who are actually running for a
nomination right now here is Trump
saying yeah our enthusiasm is way bigger
than the Democratic enthusiasm right now
you know they always talk about the
Democrats they have enthusiasm right we
have so much more enthusiasm than that's
not even close
they're all fighting each
they're all going after each other you
got a bowl over the place they don't
know what the hell they're doing I don't
know what they're doing they can't even
count their votes accurate fact check
true fact Richter so what are the
Democrats going back to they're going
back to these sort of chiding George
Conway's so desperate at this point
Kelly Ann's husband he is so he is so
desperate at this point he's suggesting
preemptively impeaching Trump again
again not kidding Washington Post
opinions today Trump is right we might
have to impeach him again he says with
essentially no pretense about why he was
doing it the president brazenly
retaliated Friday against two witnesses
who gave truthful testimony in the
houses impeachment inquiry
he fired Lieutenant Colonel Alexander
VIN Minh and US ambassador to the EU
Gordon Sunland and he also fired a third
man Lieutenant Colonel you have gun even
Minh merely for being the brother of the
first this is part of by the way of a
broader cut-down in federal staffing so
it's not wholly true that this was just
about going after these people from
essentially admitted his retaliatory
motive on Saturday when he tweeted that
he sacked Minh Minh in part for having
reported contents of my perfect calls
incorrectly if this were a criminal
investigation an Alexander of Inman and
someone had given their testimony to a
grand jury this Friday night massacre
could have been a crime at the very
least it ought to be impeachable if
Richard Nixon was to be impeached for
authorizing hush money for witnesses and
Trump himself was actually impeached for
directing defiance of how subpoenas
there should be no doubt that punishing
witnesses for complying with subpoenas
and giving truthful testimony about
presidential misconduct should make for
a high crime or misdemeanor as well so
let's impeach him again yeah good luck
with this good luck with this it's just
not going to fly you took your shot you
missed
is this a move that Trump should have
made no it's politically stupid but for
Trump the the rip on VIN Minh is that
VIN Minh was deliberately
misinterpreting what he was saying
because he doesn't like Trump personally
and didn't like his Ukraine policy that
it had nothing to do with Trump actually
committing a crime per site okay so
George Conway saying let's impeach him
again you get this from Pelosi two
Republicans have normalized lawlessness
good luck with all of this it's just not
going to it's not going to cut it it
really is not so this is the problem for
Democrats they've got an octogenarian
socialist who is now running away with
this thing hey Bernie is not only the
front-runner he is now the prohibitive
frontrunner because nobody else is
rising they just took a shot at Michael
Bloomberg who is the only person who is
in the who was in the mode of Joe Biden
Biden is collapsing Bloomberg is coming
heavy fire Pete Budaj edge is the only
one who is sort of left standing
unless amy klobuchar shows really strong
in New Hampshire there is no moderate
opposition the moderates inflict six
ways from Sunday and Bernie's gonna run
away with this thing that's just the way
it is by the way Amy Klobuchar should
win right if the Democrats had any
brains at all they would be taking a
second look at Amy Klobuchar she's the
only candidate who has won in a purple
state and won repeatedly and when
Elizabeth Warren was saying I've won a
Senate seat in Massachusetts yeah you
could slap a blue D on a bag of dog crap
in Massachusetts and would win a Senate
seat and they effectively do that every
six years in Massachusetts but in
Minnesota you have to be pretty good at
politics Klobuchar happens to be a
talented politician with actually a
pretty stellar intellectual background
and this is not coming from somebody who
agrees of the club which are a lot like
I disagree with her tremendously but the
Democrats are fools not to be looking
seriously at Klobuchar and instead be
looking at like Pete Budaj
who's the mayor of seven people and who
and whose father was a grams gram C
scholar brand Antonio Graham she was one
of the founders of the the Marxist
movement in Italy in 1918 1919 his dad
was so Buddha judge his dad was like the
guy on Graham che Gramsci Graham she can
remember how to pronounce in any case
they've got a bunch of radicals and
Klobuchar may be clubbed the chart shows
strong as new in New Hampshire and that
change is the race maybe Bloomberg
starts to pick something up but it's
looking a lot like burning a lot like
Bernie and for Trump Trump is licking
his chops Trump is just waiting to drop
those attack ads against Bernie Sanders
as well you should be because guess what
Nancy Pelosi yelling about Trump it's
all priced in it is all priced in at
this point so that is where things now I
will say that there was a great ironic
moment from the Iowa Democratic chair
yesterday so Iowa still has not really
finalized the results like they're
finally finalizing the results with the
recanvassing in all this the Iowa
Democratic chair yesterday was caught on
tape explaining the disastrous caucuses
and while he was doing so the sign in
front of him that said Iowa Democratic
Party fell down is pretty spectacular if
there are mathematical rounding errors
why can't those be adjusted
because these sheets are signed not only
by the precinct chair and increasing
second precinct chair decreasing
secretary they're also signed by
campaign representatives and so for us
they are the official record of what
took place in America even he is
realizing that this is like a disaster
area it is a disaster area for Democrats
by the way in the prediction markets and
the betting markets Michael Bloomberg is
now running second to Bernie Sanders
Peabody judge is trailing in third and
Biden is all the way down at fourth in
the betting markets Biden is the
collapse of Joe Biden is going to be
something for the record books it really
is it's pretty impressive meanwhile by
the way as I say Elizabeth Warren may be
done after this which consolidates some
of the vote for Bernie presumably some
of the Warren voters move over to Bernie
but many of those Warren voters could
theoretically move over to Klobuchar and
there are reports that the Democrats are
depressed really the there is serious
depression setting in for Democrats
because they are looking at this field
and this field is a bag of nothing I
mean Michael Tim ASCII has a piece over
at The Daily Beast today called it
they're voting in New Hampshire but this
Democrat just wants to jump off a bridge
[Laughter]
just wants to jump off a bridge yeah
yeah yeah he says New Hampshire is
voting I remember when this used to be
an exciting day it's not exciting now
it's depressing I'm depressed almost
everybody I know every Democrat anyway
is depressed it's a mess Iowa's a bleep
show and shouldn't be first anyway
New Hampshire shouldn't be second it's
totally preposterous yet the party lacks
the stones to tell these self-important
second-tier states to go stuff it the
candidates don't look like winners the
party looks like it might be headed
toward a face-off between a billionaire
and a man who wants to ban billionaires
neither of them really Democrats and
Donald Trump is gonna be re-elected that
is a hell of a take from one of your
fans Democratic Party well done all they
had to do is not be crazy and they
couldn't do it and every time it looks
like they might pull back from the brink
of being crazy they just go right back
in it again okay let's get to a couple
of things that I hate we're gonna skip
things I like today we're gonna go
directly to things that I hate
things that I hate number one so there's
an article by Kate Wagner in The New
Republic and she's very very upset about
a new order a proposed executive order
titled making a federal buildings
beautiful again the order essentially
forces a rewrite of the 1962 guiding
principles for federal architecture
which mandated that an official
architectural style must be avoided for
federal buildings the new buildings
should be exemplary of the time in which
they are built right so this means that
you have ugly-ass buildings all over
Washington DC because the 1960s and
1970s where the home of what were called
the brutalist architecture now that that
name is pretty descriptive Brutalism
it's actually named after the the French
for concrete which is called brute a I
believe my French is horrible in any
case basically you end up with
monstrosities like this this is the FBI
building which looks like it's something
directly out of the pan Opticon I mean
it looks like something out of dystopian
film horror film this brutalist
architecture with overt concrete windows
burying inside layers of concrete metal
bars on the windows I mean this thing is
just a hideous piece of crap and then
contrast that with like the Supreme
Court building all right so the Supreme
Court building is a gorgeous piece of
building right I mean this is a
classical Roman architecture or a Greek
architecture looks like the Parthenon
it's beautiful I mean there's a
beautiful building the White House is a
beautiful building go back to the
brutalist piece of crap that one is from
like 1965 the fbi's building from 1965
and again go back to let's see the the
the brutalist piece that this thing is
just a horrific piece of garbage and a
lot of Washington DC looks like that
it's not the only horrific piece of
garbage in Washington DC these sorts of
things aged badly now listen I'm no
interior decorator but let me just say
that if you were going to build
something for all time not just for the
whim of the moment and you're putting
carpet down you're dead
you don't get the green shag carpet from
the 1970s that thing's gonna be obsolete
inside of seven years but instead you do
is he tend to build in time-tested and
honored tradition and this is true for
city great cities all over the world
great cities all over the world are
built in particular style if you were to
go brutalist architecture in the center
of Paris it would you admire the
landscape obviously in Jerusalem you you
must by law build things from Jerusalem
stone so that all of the city is of a
piece and so the new executive order was
to suggest that we stop building crap
like that and instead we build some of
these classical buildings right which
are much better-looking they're much
nicer looking they're more be
they stand the test of time nobody goes
in Glocks at the at the front of the FBI
building nobody does that
instead people tend to go to the major
the major sites in Washington DC that
are nicer looking and it don't look like
they have aged I mean the White House is
a beautiful building just aesthetically
it's a very pleasing building but
according to this article by Kate Wagner
you are a racist
if you push for classical federal
buildings a racist the proposition put
forth by this new executive order which
is spearheaded by the National Civic Art
Society a conservative nonprofit what
essentially scrapped the old guidelines
in favor of a mandate that establishes a
classical style inspired by Greek and
Roman architecture as the default the
American Institute of Architects swept
swiftly published a vehement
denunciation of the plan on the grounds
who would stifle architecture and
violate the free thought and artistic
expression that are essential to a
democracy comparisons have already been
made to Mussolini Hitler and Stalin
really like because you're building nice
buildings that's like Mussolini Hitler
and Stalin I mean people should actually
like take a look at Stalinist
architecture it's hideous
it's hideous garbage if you actually go
and look at the old Soviet architecture
it's really really horrible looking the
abrupt aesthetic reversal heralded by
this executive order has some obvious
underpinnings beginning with the fact
that the reversion to a mandatory
classical style reflects the
architectural philosophies of white
supremacists online oh so it was the
4chan folks who decided that they wanted
beautiful buildings I'm confused
don't diverse people like good-looking
buildings it seems pretty obvious to me
that that FBI building is a piece of
crap it seems pretty obvious to
everybody has ever walked by it but
apparently that makes you a racist
this is the inevitable result of an
architectural full populism that has
been sown in the conscience of American
architecture since post modernism the
effort to stifle aesthetic expression in
public architecture by in stating a
mandatory style is wrong for all the
reasons that the AIA and the Chicago Sun
Times editorial board lay out in
opposition the proposal would allow
Trump to create a President's Committee
for the Reeb unification of federal
architecture which would enforce this
design mandate and this panel would
exclude artists architects engineers art
or architecture critics members of the
building industry or any other members
of the public that are affiliated with
any interest group or organization
involved in architecture speaking as an
architecture critic this is insane and
borderline totalitarian weird because
the same people who say that we
shouldn't have lobbyists deciding
exactly how anything is done in
Washington DC say that architecture
lobbyists should decide
how architecture is done in Washington
DC whether we like to admit it or not
says this New Republic columnist Trump
is an architectural president like all
building peddlers Trump is subjected to
the gaze of architecture critics who
have occasionally praised his work but
it mostly often panned it the Trump has
put up buildings ranging from 19th
century retrofits to late modern
skyscrapers his personal style is a
combination of 2000's bling and louis
xiv
his choice of modernism for the style of
the Trump Towers in Chicago in New York
can simply be explained away by the fact
that modern all glass buildings are
hegemonic aesthetic signature of
corporate capitalism is the style of big
business okay so hold on a second none
of most of trumps architecture is not
this stuff most of trumps but somehow
Trump's fascist tendencies lead to a
preference for neoclassical architecture
eventually this columnist admits
neoclassical architecture isn't always a
right wing dog whistle yeah because it's
almost never right-wing - ugh whistle
most architects are required to learn
about it in their architectural history
classes many architects trained at
architecture schools most notably the
university of notre dom that specialized
in traditional Western architectural
language these architects sometimes go
to work on new buildings many ply their
trade in restorations there is beauty
and nuance in classical architecture so
what exactly are you whining about but
apparently if you don't want those
hideous brutalist buildings then then
you're a racist so good news they're
from the nation okay other things that I
hate today so David Brooks has an
extraordinarily long piece in the
Atlantic today talking about the nuclear
family and suggesting the nuclear family
was a mistake he says the family
structure we've held up as the cultural
ideal for the past half century has been
a catastrophe for many it's time to
figure out better ways to live together
so David Brooks as he so often does
strings together a bunch of true
statements to come up with a false
conclusion this article basically
suggests that the concept of the of the
nuclear family is inherently bad that
the nuclear family is somehow created at
the expense of extended family and
community in society but society
building that is basically his premise
so what he says is that we should get
rid of this concept of the nuclear
family it's past it's time never really
applied anyway it only applied for a
short period of time and only one brutal
sexism was in order and instead we need
to create new social networks that we're
supposed to do without churches we're
supposed to do it without nuclear
families that work with one another it's
absolute horse crap so he comes up with
he critiques the nuclear family existing
in isolation without extended family but
then his solution is not okay well we
need the nuclear family and the extended
family his solution is the nuclear
family no longer exists so we have to
build these tribal structures around
around non nuclear families and he comes
up with like all the wrong solutions so
here's what David Brooks has to say
about the nuclear family and this again
is a failure to recognize that old
standards of morality when it comes to
the nuclear family you need a mom and a
dad and kids and that you should have
grandparents around and that government
structures by the way totally undercut
that right what Social Security actually
did in many cases was prevent children
from feeling the need to take care of
their parents cuz Social Security was
gonna do that it used to be 50 60 years
ago before Social Security got enormous
and everybody sort of assumed that when
your parents got older you were going to
have to build a mother-in-law unit on
your house and that your mother-in-law
was gonna have to stay there I mean then
it were literally called mother-in-law
units right there was always the
assumption that as your parents age
you're gonna have to take care of them
but government incentives changed that
structure in any case David Brooks he he
starts again from the right premises and
ends in the wrong place which is so
typical of people who are unwilling to
admit that maybe we've gotten a few
things wrong over the past 60 years in
terms of Social Policy particularly with
regard to the differences between the
sexes and the necessity of having a
mother and a father David Brooks says
the scene is one many of us have
somewhere in our family history dozens
of people celebrating Thanksgiving or
some other holiday around a makeshift
stretch of family table siblings cousin
aunts uncles great aunts the
grandparents are telling old family
stories for the 37th time the old sirs
start squabbling about whose memory is
better after the meal there are piles of
plates in the sink squads of children
conspiring mischievously in the basement
groups of young parents huddle in a
hallway making plans this particular
family is the one depicted in Barry
Levinson's 1990 film Avalon based on his
own childhood in Baltimore as the years
go by in the movie the extended family
plays a smaller and smaller role by the
1960s there's no extended family at
Thanksgiving it's just a young father
and mother and their son and daughter
eating turkey off trays in front of the
TV and the final scene the main
character is living alone in a nursing
home wondering what happened this is the
story of our times the story of the
family wants a dense cluster of many
siblings and extended kin fragmenting
into ever smaller and more fragile forms
the initial results of that
fragmentation the nuclear family didn't
seem so bad but then because the nuclear
family is so brittle the fragmentation
can
continued in many sectors of society
nuclear families fragmented into
single-parent families single-parent
families into chaotic families or no
families okay this is where his
narrative goes off the rails so it is
true that when you create a family
structure you should do so and you
should look to do so in places where you
have support structures I talked about
this on my show all the time right I
live within a mile of my parents why
well because today for example I have
like an errand that I need to run with
my daughter I'm working and my wife has
an appointment my dad is picking up the
slack right when we have our next baby
which should come sometime in the next
few weeks when that happens my parents
are going to step in and help we
deliberately live close to my parents in
order to make this happen by the way
with travel now it is also true that
having an extended family that is
available to you is much more possible
than ever before when my sister who
lives over on the East Coast has a
problem she called my parents and my mom
gets home the next plane and she's over
there and she just stays with them to
help out my wife has this baby her
parents are gonna come down and they're
gonna help out too like having extended
family available as obviously is
obviously necessary not only that having
an extended tribe and my tribe I don't
mean genetically associated I mean a
group of people with whom you have a
common interest available is really good
like when my wife has her baby and this
happens with every baby in our Jewish
community whenever somebody has a baby
for the next three weeks every meal is
taken care of like somebody in the
family we actually have like a full
schedule online and we will all claim a
meal and we'll all drop off a meal with
the family of the baby that was just
born so that the wife doesn't have to
cook the mom doesn't have to cook for
like three weeks to make sure that she's
able to take care of the kid and take
care of and the dad too and all of that
right it is true you need social
structures but what's weird about david
brooks his piece is that his argument is
that the nuclear family was a myth
no the nuclear family is an inherent
part of this the nuclear family exists
with the rest of the social structure
david brooks concludes in this piece
that basically extended clans Feliway
the nuclear family was left and the
nuclear family wasn't strong enough to
bear all the pressures that were put on
it by outside forces well that's sort of
true and it's sort of not because as
david brooks acknowledges the nuclear
family is still the standard in high
income America now he says that's
because it's easier to have a nuclear
family when you're high income this is
completely reversing the logic the
reality is that one of the reasons
people are low income is because they do
not form nuclear families as often one
of the greatest intergenerational
predictors of poverty is not forming a
nuclear family is being a single mom
right you don't have as much social
structure available to help with your
kids this is one of the lead predictors
of criminal engagement by your children
it's one of the leading indicators of
intergenerational poverty so Brooks gets
it all backwards
he says that only rich people can afford
to have a nuclear family no that is
wrong the reason one of the major
reasons that rich people are rich is
because they make good decisions about
their family right as I have cited
before if you want to be not poor in
America permanently poor in America do
three things
graduate high school get a job don't
have a baby before you're married that's
it those are the only three things and
if you violate those three things you
are going to be poor right or at least
there is a better shot that you were
going to be poor in the United States by
leaps and bounds but Brooke seems to us
it seems to assume that it's harder to
form a nuclear family these days when
the truth is it's actually easier than
ever to form a nuclear family these days
it really is it is simple to form a
nuclear family you walk down like of all
sorts by the way you walk down to a
government office you get a document now
you are married and what has changed
other than you have to file as joint
income filers which is actually a
marriage penalty the government should
get rid of other than that get child tax
credits there are all sorts of benefits
that are available to you as a married
couple to are now living for the price
of one to a certain extent because when
I got married with my wife my expenses
really did not rise all that much but
our income did if she had been working
she was a student at the time but david
brooks lament what he's really doing is
he's lamenting the death of extended
family that is fair but to lament the
death of extended family by crapping on
the nuclear family is completely bizarre
he says extended families have two great
strengths the first is resilience an
extended family is one or more families
in a supporting web your spouse and
children come first but they're also
cousins in-laws grandparents a complex
webs of web of relationships amongst a 7
10 20 people if a mother dies siblings
uncles aunts grandparents are there to
step in if a relationship between a
father and a child ruptures others can
fill the breach extended families have
more people to share the unexpected
burdens when a kid gets stuck in the
middle sick in the middle of the day or
when an adult unexpectedly loses a job
I'd attach nuclear family by contrast is
an intent set of relationships amongst a
four people if one relationship breaks
there are no shock absorbers in a
nuclear family the end of the marriage
means the end of the family as it was
previously understood all of that is
true it is also true that if you want an
extended family you know it's very
helpful having two parents involved in
the extended family even in the stories
I'm telling about my own family my
parents are involved
my wife's parents are involved right we
now have two sets of grandparents who
are able to pitch in my wife's siblings
can come over and babysit my siblings
are available if we need help and I'm
available to them in order to build a
big web a network of relationships you
do have to have a nuclear family at the
center the reason that I'm extending
this is that the title of this our
ignorant article is that the nuclear
family was a mistake no the death of the
extended family was a mistake the
nuclear family is a longtime part of
human history and his case that he makes
that the nuclear family didn't exist
until the 1950s is obviously untrue it's
obviously untrue
hey when when people were expanding
across the continent of the United
States
it was the nuclear family not a part of
that when people have expanded
throughout human history was the nuclear
family not a part of that and what
exactly is he calling for a replacement
of the nuclear family by a social
structure that is going to head it takes
a village it does take a village but it
takes a family within the village and it
takes families networking with other
families in that village so this is call
for the replacement of the nuclear
family is quite bizarre by David Brooks
and that is where he ends up right he
ends up suggesting that the cure for
lack of fathers in the african-american
family father sticking around in the
home is social networks well that can
help it certainly can but you know what
the leading indicator is of help in
those social networks father's in the
surrounding areas it Harvard did a study
where it talked about lack of fathers in
the black community and it said that a
lack of one father in the black
community can be replaced as long as the
surrounding community has a high
percentage of fathers in other words you
do need nuclear families it can't just
be a matriarchy taking care of a bunch
of kids with no father's presence at all
because they've created a social network
that is simply not going to cut it but
David Brooks ends up here he says in
other words social conservatives have a
philosophy of family life they can't
operationalize because it is no longer
relevant because it is no longer
relevant why is that not no longer
relevant why like seriously he says it's
no longer relevant because women want to
work and because the idea of a nuclear
family rests on the fact that women
women have to stay home no it doesn't if
you have an extended family then
everybody sort of shares the burdens but
you need the nuclear family it again to
provide that core he says the sexual
revolution has come and gone and it's
left it less us left us with no
governing norms of family life no
guiding values no articulated ideals and
so the progressives have no
philosophy of family life at all because
they don't want to see him judgmental so
instead we want to redefine kinship
here's the solution he says in the
beginning was the ban for tens of
thousands of years people commonly lived
in small bands of say twenty five people
which linked up with perhaps twenty
other bands to form a tribe people in
the band went out foraging for food
brought it back to share they hunted
together and fought Wars together made
clothing for one another
looked out for one another's kids in
every realm of life they relied on their
extended family and wider kin throughout
most of human history however a kinship
was something you could create well
again now he's just talking about the
loss of community generally with with
which I totally agree but I don't
understand why this is supposed to come
at the expense of the nuclear family he
says back in the 17th and 18th centuries
when European Protestants came to North
America the relatively individualistic
culture existed alongside the Native
Americans a very communal culture in his
book tribe Sebastian Junger describes
what happened next while European
settlers kept defecting to go live with
Native American families almost no
Native Americans ever defected to go
live with European families Europeans
occasionally captured Native Americans
and forced them to come with them they
taught them English and educated them in
Western ways but almost every time they
were able the indigenous Americans fled
European settlers were sometimes
captured by Native Americans they rarely
tried to run away when you read such
accounts you can't help but wonder
whether our civilization has somehow
made a gigantic mistake okay that's a
very weird example to choose given the
fact that the nuclear family and
extended kin or a hallmark of American
life for most of American history he
says our culture is oddly stuck we want
stability and rootedness but also
mobility dynamic capitalism and the
liberty to adopt the lifestyle we choose
we want close families but not the legal
cultural and sociological constraints
that made them possible we've seen the
wreckage left behind by the collapse of
the detached family yeah recent signs
suggest the possibility a new family
paradigm is emerging and here's where he
gets to his his kind of his punchline he
says many of the statistics I cited our
dire but they describe the past
Americans are now expensing
experimenting with new forms of kinship
an extended family in search of
stability he says that we're moving into
a new cultural paradigm why because kids
are staying around with their parents
and this is creating new networks no
this is incorrect again because you have
now said that a kid who is thirty
staying with mom and dad is the same as
a kid who is thirty married with three
kids living within a mile of mom and dad
not the same thing if you're going to
create kinship networks the nuclear
family remains at the sin
of that and then he has this very weird
situation where he says African
Americans have always relied on extended
family more than white Americans do he
says the black extended family survived
even under slavery and all the forced
family separations that involved family
reserve was essential in the Jim Crow
South all of this is true and then he
said government policy sometimes made it
more difficult for this family form to
thrive that is also true but this
happened identically at the same time as
the death of nuclear family in the black
community what you gonna need a lot of
nuclear families to make a network so
bottom line here is the nuclear family
was not a mistake the nuclear family is
was and will continue to be since
biblical times the standard for human
living the question is whether we can
create social fabric and that requires
commonality of interest and this is the
thing that Brooks is unwilling to say
the bottom line is all of the areas of
American life typically in which nuclear
families have formed the core of a
broader social network happened inside
religious communities and he's unwilling
to say that people need to get involved
in social networking via common interest
again because the bottom line is as
common interest fragments and as nuclear
family fragments there's nothing left to
hold this together and that is a bigger
problem so we need two things to happen
one make responsible decisions about
your own childbearing and rearing get
married have babies and two you need a
social network of common interest and
that involves seriously thinking about
your own values and getting involved
with others on a social level and yes
that might mean then we might need to go
back to church at a higher level okay so
there you have it we will be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow for the
recap of New Hampshire primaries i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel light house key
technical producer Austin Stephens
playback and media operated by Nick
she's an associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by Mike Romina hair and makeup
is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 20 hey everybody its
Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin
show you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]